well despite the winds causing some
delays at the reed international today a
special flight was right on time euros
fights from germany here to las vegas
resume service madison kimbrough just
returned from the airport with reaction
from international travelers madison a
lot of excitement inside terminal 3 this
afternoon as international travelers
made their way from frankfort germany
in the past 24 hours harry reid
international has welcomed munich
germany and zurich switzerland into las
vegas both out of adult vice and euro
wings discover airlines travel from
frankfurt germany started back up in
march with condor airlines and now
eurowing's discover from frankfurt
returned monday evening for the first
time since before the pandemic and for
the majority of passengers it's their
first time in las vegas it's great to be
out and about again isn't it
it's so yeah it's been two years of sort
of like not going anywhere we're meeting
our son tonight and we're going we'll go
for dinner somewhere tonight he's
probably arranged that hopefully because
he came yesterday he arrived yesterday
eurowings discover flights operate
between las vegas to frankfurt four
times a week and flights between las
vegas and munich twice a week the las
vegas munich flight is a seasonal summer
route that will operate up until october
28th
and next month there will be non-stop
service into las vegas from 17 different
international destinations now according
to the lvcva of 42 million visitors in
2019 5.7 were international bringing in
an economic impact of 4.8 billion
dollars to vegas reporting in the
newsroom madison kimbrough live local
now thank you madison